[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys welcome to our destiny to
launch day livestream I'm chassis and
with us we have a very special guest we
have MMA icon and Hollywood star Randy
Couture thank you for being here buzzer
I heard you love destiny and you've been
playing a lot recently I have been
playing a lot recently trying to
resharpen the skills and the thumbs and
get ready for destiny too well that's
cool well we are playing destiny to
today brought to you by destiny to you
and I'm a new player so this is exciting
for me I've only played the PC beta last
week and I had a lot of fun so I'm
excited to jump in but this will be my
first time playing as a hunter I was
playing as a warlock last week so I'm
kind of learning on the way what do you
play out I'm playing as a Titan I like I
like I like they don't change weapons
and do the things Titans do nice it's
awesome
so we will be playing as a fireteam with
our resident game spot destiny expert
Erik Tay Erik thank you for helping us
out today yep no worries our fireteam
leader and so we're gonna jump into
strikes so this stream we're gonna be
here for an hour and a half and we're
focusing on strikes today so strikes are
super fun they're cooperative you can
play with your friends you can be
matched up and play with others and so
we have two Titans and a hunter is that
what we've got yes yes all right cool
so we're gonna jump to some strikes so
when you play destiny - you don't get to
play strikes right away you move up -
once you get to IO then you get to play
some strikes
we're also hanging out in chat so if you
have any questions on youtube on
periscope on Twitch send them through
we'll try to ask him between strikes do
the best we can so what do you like
about destiny are you excited about to
play in destiny - this whole world that
is created that you kind of get immersed
in and some of you recognize some of it
obviously is pure fantasy but I think
it's just so well done that that's what
I like about it yeah you literally end
up there for hours which is amazing I
agree and as a new player I think it's
very accessible
knew the beta that I play it was very
accessible for me as someone who hadn't
played destiny before and I've been told
by my co-workers that it's really easy
to just jump in as a new player and you
don't have to play the first destiny in
order to play destiny too so I'm very
happy about that so I will be playing as
winter
all right so we're playing these strikes
we're all playing together and we have
to play against enemies he's fast oh my
gosh I already have something to write
beautiful look at this alright so here
we go
if you're just tuning in we're playing
destiny to you brought to you by destiny
to you and we are playing some strikes
today now we're down here just down
there right all right
Wow hosted you got your Randi don't
worry thank you sir he's gonna carry us
today doing the best we can
so destiny hu is really focused on
acumen story this time around so as I
was playing a little bit last night I
was really intrigued by the story and
I'm looking forward to playing more MORE
about it if you're not familiar with
destiny it's a first-person action
trigger that pulls players in with a
cinematic story that features big stakes
and pull characters and I died yeah
we're hanging out the chat so if you're
on YouTube twitch or periscope comment
or a question for us and I ask them
while I'm waiting please come on I'll
get you in a second I'm fine I have four
seconds left like a response
too bad oh thanks what a pal sure I'll
get Randy - thanks just stand over the
slaughter we got to take over those
little circles I got one of them already
there's gonna be more ads though once we
pop this take him over do I stand in
them
oh we got this one yeah so watch out
there's gonna be a bunch of monster you
lose my guess lots of monsters Oh see I
do
[Music]
yes it's gonna hide I'm all that
sneaking up Oh
ah
hello
so we are playing strikes there are
three player cooperative experiences and
you and two of your friends or match
made players throw down as against
enemies it's a lot of intense action but
it's a lot of fun
sorry guys I gotta clear this real quick
no please before I could die too
so these strikes your epic boss battle
and then when you win you get victory
and sweet sweet loot so that's what
we're after
and as a new player it's a lot of fun
this is like the everything about the
beta last week but it's also an ongoing
challenge for a seasoned vets like Eric
I'm going to try to go here and you're
nice
try to you
how didn't you do that do what he
disappeared
Oh teleported yeah
yeah
all right so we're probably playing two
strikes during this stream we're
streaming until about 2:30 or wherever
we alright come on that's practicing us
or like last night so this is all this
is this host to myself now I know it was
a longer jump that looked like give it
some time to queue up
oh hi guys let's write down yep
be careful on this spray fire John yeah
cool nice work all right
here we go fishing for
you know wake them up all right
nicely done
more jumping guys behind you Randy
oh the other way oh my god should don't
worry I'm gonna shoot from where right
down right
oh he's already ahead of the game I like
it cool we're falling you know yep well
watch out there's bad guys down here oh
yeah
Oh myself don't matter
can you get him chest oh he's all the
way up there if not he can just respond
in a second okay yeah ready
Chesapeake
[Music]
I really like it
oh yeah that was me last night so if
you're just tuning in we're playing
destiny 2 on launch day brought to you
by destiny to you when we're playing on
the ps4 the game is out today on ps4 and
Xbox one and we are playing some strikes
morning these in this area um I think oh
he's good I think cool
we'll see oh he's trying to make it he's
going all the way I think we can pull
them forward perhaps we'll see you just
avoid the lasers
I guess chest me please got it
see if we can pull him forward I think
we can
not Randy can now you can catch
everything or you can wait for him oh
wait
alright let me see if I can pull him
forward
you'll be here soon
avoid all these laser obstacles that you
guys don't see right now okay I'm down
here don't worry
[Music]
yesterday I'd see the that laser thing
up ahead yeah so I look down jump that
far there was two there should be a path
and then hit jump again a little bit
wait pretty much done cool all right you
be our chassis wash after all but
there's a lot of laser puzzles okay
we'll just jump through them I know but
go around them they hurt you if you
touch it yeah
[Music]
there's a big jump later after you get
past all the walking stuff okay
get in there what oh so just save your
junk oh wow better jump all the way over
there no [ __ ] should be straightforward
oh yeah you might have to jump over yes
okay you can jump that yes you should be
able to oh nice okay Oh toast I did the
same thing I want far enough I can't get
back to you guys
that's right I'll be there in nine
seconds
so we are hanging out in chat on youtube
twitter periscope
so on YouTube Liz James asked Randy who
would you rather play destiny with
McGregor or Mayweather I don't know do I
get a hit either one of them on twitch
Percy 1983 said what I need to play
destiny to play destiny - no I didn't
play destiny and I'm having fun playing
destiny - and I think it's very
accessible and I've been told that by
seasoned players they said I don't need
to put the first one in order to play
the second one yeah they do a good job
of bringing new people all right cool
you guys are here there's a lot of stuff
in the okay metal lasers yeah use the
cover as much as possible
you're Randy I'm gonna put a shield in
front of you okay you can use that as
cover oh these are super go use your
super ego be Captain America yeah that
way l1 won't throw your shield oh yeah
that one throws your shield oh wow
and you can't shoot them in there right
no you gotta just use your shield or
throw it you can throw it like once or
twice
thank gosh you yeah I'll try to get rid
of it right now you have three kinds of
weapons now so two of them will have
elemental damage you match the elemental
damage it'll do a little like explosion
on the bad guys
we're good
enter the warp gate virus offering
nachos oh no it's just that you
shouldn't nice this one's kind of the
same except it's like opposite it's like
every other one I can live you guys
might not be able to so just be careful
it just switches back and forth got it
and this is uh kind of the same thing
except more lasers she bites you you
guys got it all right let's see what
this one is
alternating yeah
nice work okay so this is kind of saying
oh no you guys good
you got a jump down there yeah Simon
look down oh I see it I don't think I
can get up there I'm gonna die too
yeah
now you can't thank you we can't get
back that high I don't think that jump
too far oh yeah you just drop down you
don't jump across I see
so look down it'll show up and then
disappear oh no oh you're good oh hey so
what we did in the beginning we got like
standing on the circles I think we have
to do that again all right good shot
watching your left you want to stand on
the circle yeah but be careful for right
now a lot of stuffs in there spawn taken
couple blind youth so be careful
hopefully
like that I need to respond a 4-3-3 asks
Rani deep lake on duty
I played a little bit not much
Sam
the Sun had that black ops that get
killed again
thank you
but you guys if we finish that circle
there's a thing we got to do another
circle to open it up
all right I'm gonna stand in the circle
now
stuff is gonna spawn again though
and we're about 20 minutes in if you're
just tuning in we're playing destiny -
brought to you by destiny to you we're
playing with guests we are playing
strikes today what others are captain
behind you know try me
there's a bunch of you ready yeah
they've got questions for brandy
questions for us ask them on YouTube
which periscope all the places and we'll
try to get to them while we're
respawning or between strikes here we go
here we go
laser puzzles again more laser puzzles
it goes up and down this first one it's
one working out the I assume jumped
through oh okay I'll go get him good man
four fire teams before right yes
okay the other way to make it easier
Randy's if you jump up here you can just
run through instead of jumping Hayashi
OOP John's body on parry script said
does this plan like overwatch what do
you think
no yeah cool watch out there yeah so far
I haven't had that experience but thanks
for asking
I mean there are still classes in this
game they're just not as defined as
overwatch am I getting up I got it
lasers coming from two two directions
that's alright they just wanted to test
you this morning yeah make sure you're
awake testing all of us
shot
I'll kill him you guys
it said puzzle okay
[Music]
Oh
yeah I'm never sue their picker
go all the way back yep eat it
it's like MMA training right Blazers are
tricky
I'll let you go first friends now good
all right oh this is gonna be fun Oh No
[Music]
cow
oh you can't get a hit once you just
can't get hit yeah excited to wade
through your life to come back before
doing it again if you don't are they
getting faster they're getting a little
faster
here we go okay nice work all right
hmm feels like we're at the boss are we
yeah go through putting up a shield for
you guys yeah can she do this you can't
you do it but you can hide behind it
full that works
Wow
look out there's a big cannons to the
right and lo I see him
you can only damage them when they open
up okay
ha ha Oh got me back
oh we're having a lot of fun playing
strikes and SP - I'm waiting to respond
but if you are new to destiny - so am i
but it's really accessible for new
players and it's got something for
everyone it's filled with more variety
than ever
featuring a full campaign brand new
worlds to explore and improved
cooperative TV and PvP modes but we are
focusing on strikes
so the cool thing about that shield or
handy is if your kneel behind it it'll
automatically reload your gun I'm gonna
get chastity
first thing that she'll be
thank you
go-go Captain America
[Music]
nice work
going down there not yet we got it so
we're hacking these power
feedbacks
let's check the chat we are on YouTube
twitch and periscope that you have any
questions
revive her if you can worse yet it's
right next to ya I'll be back in one
second just get out of here though right
away like that Canyon splashing or the
hydro sorry
I killed that Thank You Chester can you
hack that less that oh the turmoil to
your right yeah I'll get the one at the
front there's enemies near you though I
think
actually no I lied to you there's
somewhere else I'll get them
all right so I hacked the last one so
just be careful because I want to say or
no we're gonna have to work for you all
right
okay
yes yeah you see this all right you
ready for boss oh we went we get a bunch
of Lu tell these guys first this is
clearly some kind of job
Oh gonna stay up here once it says
entered the conduit oh nice I think we
got to go into it into them
oh wait is that down there I'm gonna go
find out I'm get back guys
all right well we're gonna investigate
oh yeah you jump in jump in yeah so mo
all we do yeah they don't bring you down
okay it'll slow mo to a challenge and
the boss is gonna come are you guys down
here tell me when you down here I'm
landing I hide behind something cuz I'm
gonna summon something bad
oh boy take cover it's gonna be a
monster robot or vex he'd like to be
called it Bex probably posture about our
Vic's that what that is that's white
light
it's yeah bad thing yeah friend
definitely not a prize yeah yeah I think
his head is his weakness
yeah that red glowy
take cover he teleported to the backside
behind you guys now in a cage easy
summoning adds the careful somebody what
monsters hey robots I think I got to go
in that circle to get him out of it so
I'm going to do that right now
Oh kill these guys so just be careful
okay oh he can shoot out of there that's
not fair yeah we can't shoot in it nope
that's not fair that's cheating
add the robots it happens I'm gonna go
get and also the other circles here
anyway so
jeans
might be in this circle yeah I'm gonna
get testicle quick you work on that so
hello
he's out now we can damage him okay
thank you
I'm standing the fire
every buyer Jeff yes
oh he's gonna teleport and hide himself
again so he's to your laughter right
chesty so watch out yeah we're gonna
stand in circles again after he spawns
more of his little robot buddies leading
the shield there
[Music]
my periscope Jill Robinson asked Brandi
what do you think of dusty - I like it
well cool hazards and in Jeff the
navigate there's more of that stuff than
there wasn't in the football oh yeah
[Music]
just be careful since you can't
how long is he staying I stays in there
total you do two circles
I don't have a shield yet testicles
all right now you can hit them watch out
for fire you're gonna do fire right now
all right it's teleporting again he's
back where he started
[Music]
Oh burnt to a crisp yeah
[Music]
we are chatting on YouTube twitch and
periscope you have any questions or
comments I will read them during my
responding moments back the game
yeah she got you
[Applause]
ah yourself wording down there middle
he's right on Randy right now watch out
he's right in the middle he just took a
lot of blocks away
be careful locks away yeah all of our
cover
I guess they should call them columns
all I got
they're back now
but he's also spawning more of his
buddies we try to get Randy right now
I'm going back
[Music]
not good place to be oh that's serious
boss
this is not good okay yeah we gotta do
that all over again
what cuz I died okay so Bo now we know
what he does there you go let's pause
for a minute okay all right so what do
you think of this right so far yeah yeah
that's a tough box yeah let's take some
questions so we are playing destiny -
brought to you by destiny - let's chat
with twitch youtube and periscope right
now so we have a question from James Roy
on youtube we said what would Randy's
advice be for someone who wants to start
MMA in their early 20s has the
opportunity passed no absolutely not
I didn't start till I was 34 obviously I
had a strong wrestling background but I
don't think the opportunities ever
passed and it's all about the athlete
doesn't mean willingness to put himself
out there find a good team you're only
as good as the guys you're training with
so I got to find a good team good advice
so what's your experience with video
games like what did you grow up on video
games well I mean I grew up in the Atari
pong era to be honest and then you know
obviously the freestanding games like
asteroids and pac-man and all that stuff
were when I was in junior high in high
school
this this kind of graphics and this
stuff didn't exist at all when I was
kind of in in that age group where
gaming was a big part of things so to
see how far it's come to see now now
I've two sons when my oldest was in
college he had Goldeneye and I could
play Goldeneye man he was just stand
behind me and just hear repeatedly and
now my youngest is 14 and and he loves
the gaming stuff he he does call it duty
I don't think even I don't know if he
has destiny one but I think he's gonna
have destiny to know yeah yeah on Twitch
Louie Guerrero said Randy did you watch
the MacGregor
I did watch it it was entertaining was
actually more entertaining that I
thought it would be I was a little
surprised that Connor got tired the way
he did he had a full camp to prepare for
a boxing engagement and go with 12
rounds as hard as you needed to go so I
was a little confused as to why I got
tired I didn't think he was hurt but I
thought it was a justified stoppage in
the 10th round he had over a minute and
24 unanswered punches I mean that's a
that's a stoppage in just about any
sport so it kind of went how I thought
it might go
I thought maybe weather would would
figure him out and and outbox him and
that's what happened
yeah and so what's next for you what are
you working on I'm getting ready to go
to Prague at the end of the month and
work on a movie called the UN agent and
kind of play it's it's a bit of a sci-fi
[Music]
yeah so it'll be I think it'll be fun I
get to play kind of the heavy the UN
agent that's covering up all these alien
abductions in Europe and is that your
idea sometimes it's fun that's the
beauty of acting is you get to say and
do things you would never do it well I
sure but what would the dream role being
you know I'd like to do some things
different it outside the box I think you
know playing toll road in the
Expendables it's been amazing and it's a
great group of guys to be around and and
to work with and to learn from but I
also think I got that role because I
bring some authenticity and physicality
to roles like that I think I have
developed more tools and more abilities
every time I get to act and so to get to
play in a romantic comedy or playing a
Western or some of these other genres
that most people wouldn't see me and
would be fun and more challenging
absolutely going back to the Expendables
what was that experience like how was it
going in for the first movie like
surreal yeah absolutely surreal we shot
the first part of the first movie down
in Brazil and I think the first night on
set when when all of the Expendables
came together was just kind of the whole
place was abuzz
because here's all these guys you know
coming together for the first scenes it
kind of just solidified how unique and
interesting that ensemble cast that
guy's was and it just rolled from there
it seemed like every movie it got a
little bit bigger the story changed a
little bit that we added somebody new
and it just continues to be that way so
like I said it's a great group of guys
to hang around and learn from and be be
around it's amazing do you keep in touch
with them many of them yes I see sly at
the gym a lot and unbreakable and
friends with Dolph and Terry I probably
spent the most time with them I see
Jason here and they're different events
and different things I get to see them
here and there for sure cool how are we
doing guys okay cool it's still there
for both of us well jump back in we're
playing Desi's last I saw I thought you
were dead
we're playing as a fireteam erekt a me
and Randy Couture are playing as a
fireteam and oh no you're by yourself so
where did we go yeah how do we join you
I sent you an invite or you can look for
me in the in your social in your friends
list gonna be hit
unable to join fire team at this time
please try again I will kill myself and
then I think you should be able to join
okay someone's here some guy just came
and I don't know who it is okay well we
will get that sorted out so we can join
there again we on earth we're gonna join
with him so for now we are playing
destiny to you brought to you by Thank
You c'n sorry how do you like playing
Titan did you have you played as the
other classes
ah no mostly just played as tight and it
just seemed to be the one that fit me
who's been helping you practice I had my
uh my wife my manager his son Simon and
he's really good yes he's phenomenal
busy plans I think he plays anything he
wants to be honest he never really he
never really said what he likes to play
he likes this game so he's excited for
this game to come out yeah and he was
one that was kind of helping me kind of
get up to speed with destiny so nice
strike because hate-filled and i can't
kick people so alright let's see what
should i do do a new one I just invited
you again yes any see any invites do it
what do I know where do I go there I
didn't send one to R and you only sent
one to you cuz I don't have a benz
all my friendless but he should be able
to join you because you guys are
friended I believe okay that work or no
or if you're in are you in the in space
are you in space right now
yeah hit triangle okay then you see my
name right yes hit X on that got it and
then join fireteam join fireteam okay
joining fire team so you're gonna join
me I think yeah I find that okay cool um
sorry he's in space too he can just hit
triangle I'm not in space um join me
[Music]
turbo join fire team all right cool all
right we're going to know a new one so
going into a new team you knew
you strike everyone so we are playing
strikes which is a cooperative way that
you can play with your friends or play
with new people and you just jump right
in and you take on enemies and then you
get a bunch of loot if you succeed we
have not succeeded yet but we will try
I'll try we will get one of you will get
one strike today we were close I mean
we're released trying to kill the boss
there yeah we were close he was a boss
for sure here we go so in strikes you
and two of your friends or match my
players Throwdown against enemies pretty
intense but you'll see
and we're also hanging out and chat on
YouTube twitch and periscope
we're finally back in the game sorry for
the technical difficulties
where's anyone that's on our side
operation like this Zavala provides
logistical support watch me the air
just so you know if you guys ever see
any like yellow canisters or like kind
of like gasoline
you can shoot those and it will cause
environmental damage shoot the yellow
canisters got it environment well don't
shoot it when you're next to it blow
myself up that that's right in my
wheelhouse
[Music]
yeah I got a hack this and the doors
open well chastity is way ahead of us
Jacob I came outside too
Vande you can't I don't think I can
shoot through that window in Porto it's
two year laughing Oh down that little
hallway to the roof
I will come get you I am right next to
you yeah
don't shoot do that jump do that it
makes you think you can but then really
can't
check for the ship issues
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's a high concentration of solar
edifieth these ships to get rid of that
[Music]
right up on to your left chastity or
right
who
[Music]
down here
[Music]
that's me I must have both with me
whereís said exhaust fan yeah I wanted
me to dump this solar toy yeah I gotta
put that ball
[Music]
[Music]
our fans on the other side okay it's
pretty far
yours need to go to eat I'm yeah I'm
running with the ball right now swords I
have outside yeah you had to go under I
just got to do it because he said I
don't know how long you want to hold on
to that yeah
slam dunk yeah it was going down that
ramp I went down yeah just go down that
that way and then you're gonna see if
there's some enemies there though right
there one right there we got each other
way
here we go I'm right to your left have
you guys ever get lost - if you hit that
big the button in the middle it'll bring
out your ghost and it'll kind of point
you the way you need to go which is
pretty nice that's what I do like my
compass GPS
[Music]
[Music]
this is we're doing it we're doing it
yeah thank you
yeah shoot the ship she's my ship out of
[ __ ]
[Music]
here we go okay what's going on in here
party hopefully yeah we're going down
I'm just trying to clear out that guy's
sounds lieutenant's aren't messing
around think we've seen the last of them
definitely if you're just tuning in we
are playing destiny - you brought to you
by destiny - its launch day and we're
playing on the ps4
what special guest Randy Couture we're
doing the best we can as a fireteam
plane for strikes today I got some
practice on the first one almost got to
the boss but now we are playing through
another strike to expose success and
victory and leave
there's two ships by the way
gotta
nice
also if you want to chat with us we're
hanging out on YouTube twitch and
periscope so get your questions in for
Randi your comments questions
suggestions try to read them while we're
responding
you guys got to go up here to go out
into the shift
Wow I got a grenade launcher stop
running
there's another ship by Randy shooting
it was good
[Music]
who chops on Luke
[Music]
let's go up the ramp yeah all right yeah
which way other way turn around
shooting you're right
oops wait for y'all
yep we're on our way
okay
[Music]
we're coming for you son got a lot to
answer for
[Music]
no sign of saw that elevators the only
way to watch out for that tank what do
the tank in here
again
everyone wall myself up there oh I died
too tiller your left the tank got me
yeah trying to be a hacker packing life
isn't easy
Oh granny don't die okay
run hide
characters yeah the respawn in five
seconds
you're good I'm good I'm thankful on
YouTube wolf Alexa what's your favorite
fighting video game you play fighting
games I was part of I was part of the EA
fight game when it came out and then THQ
before that but I was never in that game
I tried it was a bit bit mechanical I
made a lot of Street Fighter
I like Street Fighter Mortal Kombat yeah
of course I just realized that
where are you
[Music]
let's fire the tank that's not good
yeah how long was there I'm good
then you don't have to run they not
gonna run all the way back here all
right
let's take our else
then there's like another terminal I can
hack to make it easier hopefully
you won't do that well myself
Oh tanks though right there good luck us
I'll be back in three seconds yeah I got
you
fire
okay I got him I got him I got a time I
oh boy
all right it's done yay ha ha problem is
there might be another tank yeah is
there a
[Music]
he's on top so we need to get up top
okay rim
yeah you're gonna go up that way who's
enemies up there
[Music]
oh we got punted
all right the other tanks on this plot
on that circular platform up here
[Music]
[Music]
skills
oh shoot the legs the legs that will do
more damage toward [ __ ] at least
[Music]
I can make you cover
well and steady wins the race
Oh
yes yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
if you just tuned in we're playing some
strikes and destiny 2 on launch day
brought to you by destiny 2 with special
guest Randy Couture and we're hanging
out in chat on YouTube and twitch and
periscope what is this got a hack it
like a drunken sailor here power hack
the Dre Oh
that's why seasoning you know that's
that mean with this alright so this is
the boss
he's got sentry turrets made it to so be
careful
there are fires turts I guess okay yep
he's spit hot fire it's true
bad guys
install on that ramp oh no he's all the
way in the back
I put up a barrier chastity left
guys a lot of light guys go that one guy
no
all right
not today Isis terminal
and by doing now thank this Oh watch out
oh boy yeah look alive
all right we're taking this up this
thing good thing we're on right now cool
stay put
we're doing so well guys don't jinx it
bosses right above you guys now in
treating me well here he is his turrets
are up yeah kill the turrets first and
then him cuz we're just gonna keep
raining fire are you close enough to get
him
okay you got yes I'm gonna go back to my
spot thank you dear
I would say his head and his back the
jetpack thing is his weakness I'd have
to turn him like for you guys but if he
can't his back will try to hit him in
the head
just be careful if you spawn more
spirits which you call would be
opening spot at the end and running
my first time playing as owner but I'm
he is angry at me and charging come to
get you
oh he switched that watch out there's a
lot of his buddies on that side now not
friends yeah he ran ready he's really
high up to the right so don't get
tonight plan
I see
yeah I will search while he has his
buddies do all the work coming - gotcha
Randy
like reach it
trying to snipe me so you guys would be
he just rock it where's that going I'm
gonna run around in a circle until yeah
he's in a bubble right now okay guys
could've been just a player watch out oh
it could've been like a flare like come
help me
oh there's also a ship over there as
fire away it was
disable that shield we're sitting ducks
out here run there is a wave and way to
get rid of it
kill the ship first I guess
got it I got to grab something to break
his shield I think
Baddeley British I got it I got the
football in order to or the basketball
guy slam don't get that yeah more of his
buddies are coming out the door I've
seen on my screen
I'm gonna try to slam this we're good
yes yes his buddies though his buddies
are up behind you mm-hmm I got you I got
you
Oh
dogs
oh the boss is back where he was at the
beginning you're gonna get him yeah add
the dogs are out though we let the dogs
out I can't believe I did today
yep keep fighting I tried wait are you
guys both that no okay I was trying to
revive some chillin dogs yeah she has
something about this nobody call PETA
they're aliens I kinda had it coming
alright cool stock it down
more dogs oh yeah
Oh your again so on
trying to get to you chastity thank you
alright I'm gonna check in with chat see
how it's going on YouTube which
periscope you're up thank you
on YouTube John Feliciano said Randy are
we getting Expendables for Expendables
for us for starting February start
filming so that maybe we'll be out next
year 2019 that's exciting
thank you oh good boy
to the bus that's why he only shoots
that one person at a time so a very nice
shooting it means that you should be
able to see his back until you decide to
change
now he's on you guys
he's running to my side now he might
have like another fun yeah yeah he's
another platform he's parking right up
top the other side now so we're gonna
have to do the same thing
killed myself now you're sniping you
from above
we gotta get up there no we just have to
do the same thing that we did last time
you're gonna probably call a shield and
then I'm gonna have to slam dunk the
ball again and then he'll come down
again so just got a skills buddies by
killer ship when he sends up a flare
hopefully win and get that loot I will
come get you crazy yeah he's a toddler
on the other side night opposite where
he was the first time got it he's he's
on me right you guys should be able to
shoot him unless he has a buddies out
right now nope he's aiming at you guys
no back on me
all right he's hauling a ship get ready
for yep the ships coming in right now
and his buddies are spawning - right -
you're right Daphne they're all next to
you
another [ __ ] yep another ship
[ __ ] yeah shoot this ship and then I'll
slam dunk it and you should come back
down then we should be able to kill
assuming I'm not jinxing it now who's on
this bubble
oh my wait
I just got to get him out of his bubbled
frame like I am running as fast as I can
guys coming yeah definitely has friends
he's probably gonna come down in a
second oh I set the taro how come get
you it was so we could get him off to
his platform I think he should be back
where he I know he's on that he's lower
level now shooting Randy you got him
Jesse
18 seconds
right there I got oh my god
whereas our friend the boss is very nice
I ran it again to closed area
surrounding smashing me
Here I am yeah he's right past that
corner
forget your grenades and like heavy
weapons if you have
oh he's gone
these flying snipers on opposite corner
so just be careful
oh we're out what's going on this day if
you're running low on holidays hi-yah no
reason to rush it he's chasing me right
now
[Music]
back should be to you testing the ice
holding gun
[Music]
ah so close
ah pretty wet
[Music]
he's dead look at that you got it yeah
dead bodies here victory and the loot is
somewhere else I think 32nd loot oh it's
over here follow me
jumping Titan behind you Randy turn
around you want you to leave come this
way right way up here yeah yeah there's
a bunch of stuff up here nice just run
into that blue stuff good job guys we
did it I was cool that was fun it was
cool those nice serious bosses though I
mean you get it you're gonna really be
on target yeah you really do but no God
but it was a few I died a handful of
times myself but yeah that was fun I
think I was starting to get to hit it
better during the second straight times
got a little disoriented but that's just
my lack of skill same here
yeah we're all new to this so thank you
guys so much for watching this has been
destiny 2 brought to you by destiny -
Thank You Randy foreclosure thank you
for playing with us but and defending
and getting all the loot for we did it
we're successful we're leaving at Ojai
no we're not gonna play yeah gotta go
out on top and for all things GameSpot
is the place for destiny too so be keep
watching because we have lots and lots
of destiny to coverage coming your way
and have fun playing the game it's out
now on ps4 and Xbox one and if you're
looking to play on PC that's on October
24th so see you next time
[Music]